hello and welcome to a tutorial with the
hottest mic in the west my name is matt
you're watching code tech tutorials
today i'm going to talk about how to get
includes
libraries and linkers set up and visual
studio
this is not going to be an all-inclusive
just because there's so much but i'm
going to show you like the basic open
source way
and i might do a couple videos on this
to explore some of the other ways like
you can use vc package manager
for example but i'm not going to cover
that here that'll be another topic for
another video
i'm going to talk about the more
standard open source way of doing it
and basically where to find the settings
for your project what to look for
and what buttons to press so your
support is greatly appreciated on this
channel please don't forget to
comment like subscribe all that stuff
and if you want to go further you can
you can help on patreon i do stream also
about once a week
so you can catch me on stream too i'll
leave a link somewhere
that's probably the best place to ask
questions live otherwise comments
i don't always get to but i try to all
right so let's go
and go ahead and get into this we're
using visual studio 2019
and that's the latest right now and i'm
just going to
go ahead and open this we'll do a new
project so i'm going to do create a new
project
and we're going to do an empty project
from scratch and of course we're using c
plus plus i'm going to change this reap
actually this repo location is fine
project one sure name doesn't matter too
much
i'm not going to be uploading this or
anything just because it's
yeah i don't think it's that sort of i
don't think it's necessary
okay so when you get an empty project it
sets you to debug x86
this is kind of crucial as we will see
so if you want to add things to your
project if you want to add libraries
the most basic way is to right click on
your project level right here or you can
go to file
or see one of these project properties
or press alt f7 there's many ways to get
to this
but basically you want to get to this
properties menu
the project properties and
up here before you touch anything look
at this configuration up at the top
it'll say configuration and platform
now the most universal way to do it is
to just set all configurations at once
because these are all several settings
if you set them up for release
then it doesn't affect your debug at all
and you might like be missing your
libraries and confused
and that's because your debug isn't set
up they're just completely separate but
if you do all configurations it changes
them all at once
so that's where you see this different
options that means for different
platforms and for different
configurations there are different
options
now typically you want to leave these
alone especially for your output
directory because it'll create like a
debug or release folder
based on how you're building
so you typically want to leave those
alone all right so first
let's look at includes
okay includes linkers and libraries so
there's no c
plus files in here so so all we see is
vcc
plus plus or vc plus plus directories
and you can set them up here
but once you start adding c plus files
so if i go here and just
add a new file right click add new item
just do a just a source file we'll leave
it named source one
and it appears and we'll just do like an
ant main
something here return
0 sure whatever so it doesn't really do
much but now when we go to our
properties
we'll see that there's c plus plus here
because of text c plus code
so this is what it's going to use when
processing your c plus plus files
uh you so you can really use either of
these i like i personally like to use
the c plus plus one but
this one let's just use this one because
it's you can set it up before adding
files i guess that's the big difference
as far as i know
all right so when you want to include
stuff you're typically looking for
headers
and what you want to do is change this
include directories and it has some
default stuff it has
your sdk windows path and your vc
include path those are already in there
so anything in your environment is
already good to go
but if you click on it and you get a
little drop down carrot over here and
you click that and you just go to edit
you can start adding lines and these are
paths on your computer you can click
here
and actually path to something so for
example let me just go
and i'll i'll find a header only library
like
glm which is a linear mathematics
library that's often used for graphics
especially opengl and vulkan and that
sort of stuff
and i know i have them under my let's
see data drive
and then repos and glm
and this has a bunch of there's a bunch
of headers
you can't see them here because it's the
way it's sorted it's only looking
it's only showing folders but if for
example i
open up my file explorer and go there
you'll see in this glm there's a bunch
of headers hpp files
and of course we can look at it look at
one real quick
and see that it's just a header file and
glm itself is a header only library so
if you want to use it this is literally
all you need to do
so we will pass to it we'll click here
and go to repos glm and this is where
you do it you just hit select
so there we go so we hit okay hit okay
and now when we go to our source what we
can do is we can
include glm and it'll
start seeing it right away so it has
this auto fill stuff
and we can include parts of it and now
we can actually use the library
it includes things like in the glm
namespace
a vec3 called uh
i don't know we'll just call it v3
and boom now we have a vector three
which is just three floats
and of course use the header as as you
would however
but so there's how you get include setup
and i'm gonna show you how to do one
that now has
libraries that you have to build so if
you go it back in here and you go to
properties
and you'll now see this has the include
directories cool
but say we also want to include
something that is
that has more so add another one click
the button
go to data find repos and let's for
example add
we'll use we'll use ogre
sure ogre i did a tutorial on ogre
recently this is pretty standard
for most libraries so you go to it and
since we're doing the includes we're
going to look for the include folder
this one unlike glm is not the root you
just have to look at the library and
analyze that
so typically you want ogre main and then
include and there we go
so now it has it in there the include
for over main and we hit ok
and there's more to ogre it needs a
library to link against and it also has
a dll which is a runtime library so we
have to add those as well
you won't necessarily see that right
away but as soon as you try to build
when you're using ogre you can error
with linking if you don't have the
linkers in there and if you manage to
get past that and actually run you'll
get an error or can't find the dll if
you don't have the dll so you need
the static linker library and the dll i
guess it could be a shared
linker library so what you do here is
you just go to the linker
and go to input and you'll see
additional dependencies
but hold on first we go to general
and you'll see in here additional
library directories
so you click that and go to edit and
then you want to once again path to a
folder
that has your libraries so we'll go back
there
go to the same spot go back to ogre
now i've got to talk about something
else for this to make sense
so we go to where it built so
that is going to be in the out directory
in the build directory now if you built
the if you
downloaded the binaries directly you
just point to the binaries
and you'll see that they look the same
so right now we are pathing
to where the libraries are that's the
out build
live that's just where i've built them
and we built as mensized release and
here we go
now you can't see them there so because
it's only looking at folders
but if we go to it and go to out
build live in size release
we'll see that there's all these dot
live files
so that's what we want and now we can
link to any of these for example
since we included over main we're
looking at ogre main here we need to
link to obermaine.live
so basically we need to type that in let
me move that
not here so we know the path to it very
good so knows where to find it or what
path to check
other than the basic ones that already
checked now we go to input
and under additional dependencies click
the little carrot click
edit and then here add the one you want
to link
and you can add as many as you want and
hit ok
so now we're actually good to build
anything that uses ogre main
since we have something to link against
and one of the last things here for this
is the runtime libraries
if it has a dll that goes with it you
need that at runtime
and of course it looks in like your
default windows directories but
you're not going to have a lot of them
so what you can do here is well
you basically want to go to build events
and then post build and add a command
line
command this is about the most
recommended way
of doing it and what you do here is you
want to copy this dll
to wherever you're running your
executable from and it'll
generally look something like this x
copy
okay here's the x copy documentation
slash y well is basically auto yes
suppress prompting to confirm that you
want to overwrite
so that way it automatically does it in
the slash d we're going to do
only copies if the file has changed so
if it's the same dll we don't want to
copy it on every build
only one time unless that dll was
updated
so that's what this slash d is going to
do
slash d and then we need the path
uh the path to the dll
and here we need the directory to where
it goes
so in the directory to where it goes we
know
there's a macro and visual studio called
outdir
to take it there and as you can see it
auto filled that out
but we need to get the path to where the
dlls are
and let me just show you how to do that
well i know that it is on my d
drive and i also know
that it is in repose and
then ogre
and then out and then build
and if i look at the ogre folder i can
figure out the rest let's see out
build bin these are typically in bin
and there's debug and there's release
so there's a dll there's another dll
there's a couple more dlls
and here's a whole bunch so we actually
built them in size release
so these are the ones we're mainly
looking at
now this is actually a little scuffed
because
well let's see is there okra main yeah
there's ogre main
the ll so that's the main one we're
going to need
but typically what you do is you add
some macros in here i'm using the wrong
slashes i'll fix that
so typically you use the macro
configuration and that will
change it to either debug or release
based on what you're building
and that should do it okay i guess we
need the name of it
over main.dll so this is going to mess
up because it's going to look for debug
or release
and when we built ogre we didn't build
those so i'm actually going to go
build ogre for release and debug so that
this will work correctly for both
release and debug on our project
ogre solution that was created with
cmake
switch this to release
and we're going to do an all build which
is going to take quite a while
okay that all builds successfully we're
also going to go ahead and build
the sdk which is the install target
now we're going to switch it to debug
and do the same thing
okay then we want to do the install on
the debug
okay it looks like there's a little bit
of error on the debug and it's mostly
about this asim
model loader not a big deal but just to
point it out
in case you run into something like this
it says it's looking for
all right let's see build md
dynamic release but it's looking for md
with a lowercase d dynamic debug
so uh that's
that's why that is so our debug one
might not work but that's
that's fine we're not going to worry
about that a whole lot let's go ahead
and close ogre now that we've got those
builds updated
to better match our project and just go
back to our project
so now this configuration should
actually find what we're looking for
and as you can see it says debug for
that configuration spot
because we're on debug so we're going to
go ahead and apply that
and hit ok and now when we switch this
to debug or release
it'll get the right dll and copy it into
our out directory
that way the program will actually run
i'm going to go ahead and pause this and
go ahead and get some ogre code in here
and that way we can just see it run with
these linkers and includes
set up properly
in the ogre repo there is a samples
folder
that has all sorts of code we're just
going to use some basic tutorial code
and use that
okay so i went ahead and put in the code
from basic tutorial 2
and we can see that this also uses
application context over application
context over input over rt shader system
and over
camera man and it doesn't see these
because we only included the ogre main
which takes care of this first one
but doesn't care take care of these
optional components so we do have to go
back in
and add those components as well for
this to all work
and as you can see we're using
yeah we just brought in the class as a
class and in our source file
we're just going to try to use it
so let's go ahead and fix that up and
add everything else we need to add in
this is essentially going to be the same
as before we just go
ahead and go to the include directories
and include the other ones we need
components bits
include that will give us those headers
over components
rt shader system include
let's apply all that and let's just see
if it fixes all the headers
looks like it does fix all those headers
but we still don't have a few more
things
so we have to sort those out as well
and for building these samples ogre also
needs the samples common include
which just has some stuff that they use
in those files
i'm going to go ahead and x out glm we
don't need that
and if at any point you get a little
stuck you can always switch this to the
configuration you want
and you can get some hints as to what's
wrong by just
building it and seeing what kind of
errors you get
you see the first thing it has a problem
with is it can't find over build
settings
and this is in well this is called ogre
config
this is a config that builds so we need
to include that
now this is just out build include
and let's go ahead and hit this run
again
and see what else we get we're seeing
all sorts of stuff here
let's start at the top look for the
first error
access align box minimum class
needs to have a dll interface to be used
by clients of the class
so that's just a warning
we can skip over that for now we're
looking for the errors
so at the bottom we see that the main
thing is the application context is
still undefined in input listener and
keyboard event
this was just a namespace thing these
are in the ogre bits namespace and i
didn't put using namespace
in the header because you're not
supposed to do that
i only put it in the cpp object so
that's why it was complaining in the
header but not anywhere else about that
so now let's build again and see what we
get
as expected since all the code was fine
it built okay but it had a problem at
the linker and that's because we also
need to link over bits
and those other ogre components that we
have now included and are using so let's
go ahead and do that
and it's going to be about the same as
before so we're all done with the
includes it looks like let's go down to
linker
and add some more paths under general
here
actually
we want to completely change this we're
going to change this
to that configuration macro
so that way it looks in the folder that
we're building for
ok apply
and let's just double check with ogre
that that is the case
ogre oops
out build
live then we have debug and release as
expected
so we're mainly going to be going into
this folder with that configuration
macro
and grabbing what we need and of course
we're going to need
ogre rt shader system
and the other one ogre bits
so let's go ahead and put those in there
under input
okay we've added those in so we can hit
ok
and apply
and okay and let's see if it builds
successfully now
it looks like it did pretty good except
that it failed on
the x copy it looks like
it says it didn't find the ogre main dll
so we must have something slightly wrong
with this
pathing so let's look into that
and if we look closely at the pathing we
will see
that it's only one slash not two
so i had 2 in there and that's why it's
not finding it to copy over
so we can just go sort that out by going
back to our properties
going back to build events post build
and just fixing that
and while we're here we also know that
we're now going to need those other dlls
for over bits and over rt shaders so
let's just copy this
and we'll do an x copy on those as well
so instead of ogre main here we need
ogre bits copy that dll over
and we want to make another one for the
ogre rt shader system
that'll bring that over another thing
ogre wants
is configs so we do want to x copy those
over as well
looks like ogre puts those in the bin
file where the dlls are
so that's pretty easy to get to looking
at the release ones here
there's a resources.config i think
that's the main one we need
so we'll just go back in here and make
sure it copies
resources.cfg also to our outdoor
and there just is one other problem with
this
upon further inspection looks like the
error is pretty simple we just forgot
this bin
keyword after build so we should be able
to take care of that
and actually our macro might work so i'm
going to just try a few things and
come back with the results with the
ben now in there and just see if it
works
so here we go and it does
and we're just having a few other errors
it looks like it's not getting the z
light so we can copy that over the same
way with xcopy
since we need it
got it added in there hit ok apply
let's try now we're going to get some
errors most likely
looks like ogre overlay is also needed
for this execution so we'll add that one
in there as well
i've got ogre overlay added in there hit
okay
i'm not sure if we need the header and
linker for ogre overlay
i guess we will find out but basically
you can keep doing this until you have
no more errors it looks like it needs
sdl too so again go ahead and get that
copied over
as well
just double checking that sdl 2 is in
there as expected
looks like it is so we went ahead and
added it to the x copy
and looks like it's going further
and it did have some sort of error here
could not load a dynamic library
for the plug-in dot scene
and i'm pretty sure this is a
configuration error so i'm going to
check
that and fix that real quick so i added
this
plugins and upon further inspection
since i copied over this plugins file
it basically says the plugins folder is
where the run time is and this is what
they're all looking for so basically i
need to add all of these in
to the dlls is what's happening in this
case
so ogre is a bit of a convoluted case
but you see the point i'll go ahead and
fix this all up the rest of the way and
we'll wrap this up
okay this will probably save somebody
tons of time so
yes i had to link or put all these dlls
in there
that were in that config but also there
were two that weren't mentioned
and it was a little obscure to find
and that was ogre terrain and over
paging
which are needed by the dot scene one
for it to run
so i had to put these in here as well
and the way i figured that out is i
basically went over
to the ogre project and look at looked
at its configuration and saw that it had
terrain and paging also
mentioned in there for the dot scene and
once i put those in there it suddenly
started working
and i can pick a rendering system and
i'm going to use
directx 11 here and let's see what
happens
cross those fingers
no seems to be okay and we got our scene
generally here a little dude shadow and
all that
so i hope this helps you get your
linkers and libraries set up to include
other libraries that you've downloaded
and maybe built or have the binaries for
these are generally the steps and
generally the same for about every open
source library out there you can find
so let me know if you have any questions
below
and uh happy coding so quick recap here
for the very end
just in case things got convoluted and
you don't feel like going back
the main thing you want to do is you
want to put all your includes in the
directories
of these c plus directories under
include directories
and under the linker you under general
you want to put in all the paths to your
static libraries and under
input is where you actually want to link
them
and then you can use build events like
the post build event to
x copy over dlls which will only do it
once or if they're updated
you can also use it to bring in other
one-time things
stuff like that it's it's a nice
function functionality to
take advantage of since it automates it
and those are the core things so if i do
a second episode i'll go over more
based on the questions i get and other
things that happened since then
peace out guys see in the next episode